A woman's tears may not only invoke romance in Hollywood,...
...Mamie Parker says she's experienced firsthand what her tears can do to a man.
"If I cry, they just seem to be more affectionate and more touchy-feely, more,...
...in some cases, sexy.
But a recent study found just the opposite is true...
...when a man is close enough to smell a woman's tears.
In a Skype interview with VOA researcher Idan Frumin...
...at Weizmann Institute of Science in Israel says...
...he and his colleagues found that after men sniff women's tears,...
...their testosterone level drops 10 to 15 percent.
Researcher Yaara Yeshurun is one of six women who donated her tears for this study...
...by watching "Terms of Endearment" and other sad movies.
She says the effect of women's tears on men...
...could be another way to lower testosterone as a treatment for prostate cancer.
Weizmann Institute scientists say...
...they would also like to study how the chemicals in the tears of children and men...
...affect others.